hello Brad we are live live streaming
ahead of the producers guild awards and
congratulations on the honor tonight how
are you finish oh it's nice you know I'm
really proud of the work we've been at
this for maybe 17 years and the films
have been able to put out so and
everyone else you know how you know you
get to the end of the year and just just
been all these films but it really takes
some pushing a lot of nurturing it for
years and years to get it there so these
people knows what it takes we gotta give
you credit sir cuz you've been having
some fun this award really people loved
your Golden Globe speech I mean at this
point your career because obviously that
you're no stranger to the award circuit
and you've been part of such amazing
films what does it mean to be recognized
in this way for Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood with your pals Leo and Quentin
well I can't you know you never know
what's gonna land it's always fun when
the film really speaks to to wide
audience you know anymore the older I
get the experience is every bit as
important and those guys Brad you kind
of joked on a podcast you said your
life's a bit of a disaster but it
doesn't seem that way alright it's
alright Marc Maron yeah myself with him
I love him it's one of the funniest
shows I've ever seen if you haven't seen
it the Maron show how have you been
celebrating I mean your family know you
gave your mom a little shout out at the
Globes how have you been celebrating
this great year and all the recognition
with the family with the kids well
really I mean it's right you know so
we'll do that when it's all said and
done I'm sure I saw an interview said
you're gonna start dancing again right
after a long break from Diaz you did
dance moves and what are you trying to
dance Brad no no you know I still my my
dance kind of stagnated since prom you
know it hasn't really grown or evolved
since then so I think it was time to
work on that loves you give him Bradley
Cooper that shout out to he's been an
important
he's good as gold all right Brad thank
you hey congratulations
[Music]